6 14 on your Wednesday wonder what's
driving you crazy how about a viewer
email talking about a left turn signal
that might be on the fritz in the near
Southwest Valley
Tiffany writes a couple of weeks ago I
was trying to make a left turn onto
Hacienda from North on Rainbow wanted to
get over to Durango but I never got a
green light I watched the lights change
at least six times for all other traffic
I waited for traffic to clear ended up
making an illegal left turn because the
light was red nobody would let me in
same thing happened about a week later I
called the city of Las Vegas number they
said I needed to call Clark County but
didn't have a department name or number
it's scary and dangerous yeah legal term
is never a good idea Tiffany as we
looked at the Regional Transportation
Commission camera in the area did take a
while for a truck to make a similar left
turn so I'm sending your concern to the
RTC so they can look into it in the
meantime for you and anybody else with a
similar issue you know what they say
they encourage phone tips because
sometimes that's the only way they find
out about a problem the phone number
702-901-8400 we do have it in the online
version of this story when you visit
8newsnow.com click on traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up Drive
carefully please put down that phone
join the driving you crazy conversation
at traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com